damn
straight up broke his mic oh i think oh
wow that's broken
is it broken you can't screw it back in
no that's broken it's broken broken
there's someone just use this one for
today
i'll just grab i have another mic thing
it's fine oh you have like a mic mic
you have like a no i've had issues with
these before
once it breaks like this it's done i
mean you slammed into it you know it's
kind of
not really i'm about being single
seeing double making triple oh come on
you remember that
oh yeah that one i don't know that one
yeah
no you guys watch world star hip hop
anymore no
once homeboy died what was his name once
q died it's definitely gone down here
the russians took over when they used to
have the populations
no russians take over let them know
yeah it's just not the same it's not the
same it's still good you still get you
know your flight [ __ ] on there what is
it what does world star hip-hop
have to do with russia they just bought
it they just took it over when q died
they took it over
cool bro but they used to have like dope
like compilation like
girls twerking come on the fight videos
they had
the fight that's all you that's all you
know the twerk videos and i don't know
what it is but
there's like a ton of like domestic
violence on there
yeah now people just catching it what
how are people just catching them my
friend made the world star hip-hop fight
video he he got knocked out he made it
knocked out like he's still kind of
making it yeah that is that's all i like
because
think how think about big world stars to
where now
any time there's a fight you will always
hear a world star every time
yep especially when they go to sleep i'm
like bro his brains out
and then people are people are
uncreative because every single person
goes you got knocked the [ __ ] out
like the chris tucker thing oh hey like
grow up
grow up put a world star in come boom
you ever see the dude that got beat up
uh
outside the corner store the gas station
he was like i'm from new york
i'm from new york and then he kept
shouting to these he got beat up by
these big old
construction dudes big old burly white
man skinny black beat the [ __ ]
oh my god i watch all of that he was
like a meme for the longest time because
he was like
uh i don't know dude was just like
punching him from the back like that
like that
there's a lot of girl fights bro it was
always it was two black girls that were
guests they they had two black girls
that couldn't speak you saw that it was
over a man over a man
because they were like no no again they
were getting aggressive be
honest britney are you serious be honest
that fight was quiet as hell
oh yeah it was yeah it was like a silent
fight
that's a silence yeah that's the
definitely that was the definition i'm
gonna let my hands do the talking
okay oh you're one for one right now
okay
um like more people don't realize like
the damage they're doing to these people
on the street like
they'll be in a fight and you just see
some dude [ __ ] heel to face
on the concrete
the consequence of that i'm like how do
more people not realize what they're
doing
here's the thing or when they like
soccer kick him in the head it's like oh
and i realized like you're gonna kill
the camera you're going to kill that
a girl died uh a high school girl died
when she got jumped in the bathroom it
was a report uh
in school and all the people got
arrested uh they're like teenagers i
think she's just
she just had herself like a lot of times
i'll see like a one punch knock off yeah
where the doobie talks she's like really
really
boom and then you see the guy go cool
yeah you're like
dude yeah you're going away for the rest
of your life so he died that's how my
friend got knocked out and made a world
story really
yeah i i was like man let him up there's
like now we're gonna take his money i
was like well hurry up
i i wanna i will i saw what he got yeah
yeah
he was cool though well i i saw one of
you talking about all right sometimes
there's justice on there though like
there's this one like older white dude
talking [ __ ] to these like teenager
black kids and you call them the n-word
mm-hmm they're like
they're like they're like you trying to
get fired kitchen
i got you i got you vinegar oh okay
vinegar
say that ninja uh yes he was talking
[ __ ] these black kids skateboarding
and then he'd call him the n-word then
you see him like six and circle around
him with these
boards man and he's talking says the n
word again they just see one little
little dude backwards hat just take your
skateboard and go
i mean hit him with a skateboard and but
then
you know these they're young kids so
they don't realize it then they're just
stomping old dude out
oh i bet he woke up like
i hate i hate the i hate the like flurry
punches when they just be
well yeah yeah i was like some of those
girls on there my god damn [ __ ] with a
little bit of training
hey top 15 in the band weight division
right now in female ufc fighting can we
be honest
when a black girl uppercut you and she
say [ __ ] [ __ ]
is it like a strength power [ __ ] [ __ ]
i'm like but they keep doing they keep
going
[ __ ]
but then they do that and then some of
them if if they're mad enough
like if she [ __ ] her man they go [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] and she's like let go my
hair like over here yeah
yeah that's a little girl and then i was
young
they get their fist full of hair and
they start talking [ __ ] to him i told
you about coming over here with my my
hot cheetos or something
i saw one big girl because she found out
this girl was [ __ ] her man
is it in new york she grabbed her by the
hair and dragged her we're beating the
[ __ ]
but taking her through the neighborhood
oh i remember that and that wasn't
guess it's impossible to get someone's
fingers out of your hair when they have
it
because she was like just dragging her
through like the [ __ ] burrows of new
york being like this
she [ __ ] my man everyone's like what
and she didn't do it
[Applause]
my girl was saying last night that we
was watching housewives of potomac and
candice got her hair pulled by monique
much love and she she like yo that hurts
when it's weave is her words because
it's sold in
so we can't when it was like let her
hair go and let her hair go it's sold in
her they need to do it like lizards like
if you go to catch a lizard and you
ground by the tail
they have a mechanism where they just
let the tail go like see ya
girls need that with braids they do just
like a corridor like
see ya well you got to have the right
legs get a parachute
a parachute oh like yeah okay escape
valve yeah all right
enjoy the hairband
right there and it should be right there
like bobby like to be saying somebody in
the middle throat area
and then the hair go off and she just
starts firing like yeah it's i love that
prank it's a prank
where's your last street fight you ain't
been in a street fight in a minute now
nah oh
i saw a street fight true story in
atlanta scared the hell out of him how
long ago
uh two years ago yeah they're violent
over no but they i didn't you know
and much love but i didn't know that
it's a lot of undercover dudes out there
right
so gay boys gay boys atlanta they call
them download
download download not download though
they're just downloaded if you're not
hip to the scene
i mean i mean atlanta is basically west
hollywood like
it's gay gay over there really yeah
atlanta
but but atlanta is so more flambo this
fight they were i didn't know they were
gay like big dudes
and then like yo that apparently they
was fighting they do this all the time i
was at the gas station
i don't know if you like circle k but
you know okay circle k
gas station i didn't know they started
fighting outside so i'm like i'm gonna
watch it
then the big dude like a big dude like
i'm talking about like your size
and another guy kind of like your size
and they were fighting in the dude duck
and they just started grabbing
a couple of big bears i was so invested
in the fight i promise you
i'm not even making a joke at the end of
the fight they started kissing
really i promised to guide up dude i
promised to god
i didn't know what to do i didn't know
what to do atl i mean respect
respect i mean they imagine you watching
a fight and then like they on the ground
wrestling and he's like this is what you
want me
oh i swear i was like oh [ __ ] i mean hey
i mean hey i was like wait up there you
can respect that that's the
definition of kissing and making yeah
what do they call that good
sportsmanship
and when you have a fight and you say
yeah you know what i'm talking about
after you win a fight or some [ __ ]
you beat a motherfucker's ass and y'all
cool about it yeah that why can't people
do that
today yeah i mean you ain't got a kiss
me you gotta suck them off after you
ain't gonna
yeah yeah i mean wait wait that wasn't
is that a circle okay
i'm sure okay that's circle yeah i mean
it sure got pretty hot and heavy i'll
tell you how hot and heavy is this
firing guns in dallas
oh yeah we did that y'all killed it
you are not killed you are not familiar
with uh guns
why would you say that because we saw
the way you shoot well let's listen
can i see i didn't see the video yet
just start more peter this video is pure
fire [ __ ] is
i made the game winning shot though so
i'm gonna play this one time around but
i
have to play again without music because
it's a drake song so i'll let you guys
hear it first
oh okay okay it's hype with the dragon
oh this is hard this is my first time
sitting look at
okay hold up let me refresh hold on
refresh new music
let's turn it up too look at britney
looking like
we look like an actual fortune we look
like entourage
okay brenda calm down yeah we gotta have
a coffee mug who can bring his coffee to
a gut rate i know right
okay okay okay
you know wait hold on why'd you do this
wait
i look like childish gambino when this
is america my favorite part is the end
oh we're all with the semi look at clock
bob
look at jay jay's thick ass
okay first of all this dude's shot way
more shots exactly
exactly six out of ten it's kind of hard
with that ar-15 wait when did you shoot
would you look at this oh look at you
yeah hard yeah edit is dope oh
damn yeah
it was great the gun boys the gun boys
boys
young boys can be fun boys we shooting
okay
we shoot we
you know
yeah busting nuts and bullets you know i
really appreciated uh
doing that i mean it gave me like a new
look at uh guns and stuff yeah you know
i mean i just
never really got into that world but i
don't know just the
the knowledge that they have and how
informative they were like
i was just explaining like you know the
safeties of it there's a lot to go into
it
yeah a lot which i was like oh i warned
you guys before we went i've done a lot
i've
shot a lot of guns but it's like you
shoot right you shoot you're like oh
this is sick yeah but then you got
another 45 minutes of that [ __ ]
yeah after that like once you get over
the initial like
excitement then it's like damn my back
that's all tight come on
yeah yeah yeah yeah tell me where you
guys want girls like uh not many
you did like once you got it you got it
my favorite was the shotgun thing we did
where it was like
he didn't get tired of this yeah that
shotgun's hard
yeah that was hard but it was fun i
liked there's a lot of kick to it
a lot of kicks in that one that was that
big saturday was a nice little day
because
a nice little day really yeah we went
from gun shooting and [ __ ] with them
giant hornates
to barbecue oh those hornets were huge
the walls was it or wasps oh my god
biggest this is why it's dangerous
that's telling chin this one below the
belt because
those [ __ ] giant ass [ __ ] wasps
come around
you got a gun your reaction not to me
just take it like you know you're like
done like this so what did he explain
colin explained it what did he say just
don't
just just don't mess with him yeah like
don't that couldn't be like he said yeah
just ignore him people saying
oh that's pecan lodge dick
look here the hair goes we're going to
eat that all by himself yep right people
think that it's a lot of food for one
guy like god get
smarter here's this this guy goes you
got to quit with this texas has the best
bargain until you eat real kansas city
barbecue
hey levy kelsey21 been there
but i've been there multiple times it's
not better dude
i hate how they force their opinion on
you like they gangbanged in my dms
they did they did they was like brett we
don't try
that was fire we went to two plus two
spots uh
it's not the best it i didn't tell you
guys it's the best well we went to
still good with the lockhart which is
good at brisket yeah no i'm sorry
lockhart's good at ribs uh decent at
brisket and then
uh pecan lodge really good at ribs
decent with brisket so they're opposite
and you don't eat red meat so
what the [ __ ] are we doing well well you
just ate the chicken
by the way the same everywhere though
you know no no it was juicy it was a
little tender i loved it
okay maybe i was going hard on that uh
turkey yeah that's turkey
did you know stevie still ate healthy
there too he got smoked turkey and cole
slaw
i was like who does you don't need bread
oh but no
but uh we you guys didn't do this we got
coffee then we got pies
me and him both got pies afterwards oh
yeah and then after the pie we got ice
cream i was about to say that keep going
he went hard that day
i was i came in i was like it's giving
me my cheat afternoon
cheat afternoon but stevie don't let him
fool you stevie did it with me
wait wait i saw him eat was pie no he
had ice cream too did he had ice cream
oh yeah he went after we all went i
think
wait how sneaky you gotta be to like
yeah i'm gonna just wait till they just
like i mean all the time
uh something bad was uh the chicken
tenders at the club
by the way at the club those were great
tick fire by the salmon
as salmon was to die for did you have
another one that's all i had it is
interesting because everyone at the food
at the the improv would eat their salmon
over quinoa and spinach like a healthier
option
fish out of clubs a little dicey wait
what what what it's just not what they
do
like that there's no way that salmon's
freshly caught you feel me
like they specialize in like deep-fried
food we had
six yeah don't get me wrong it was
delicious yeah when you think about it
that can't be fresh salmon
yeah come on boys it says
you said alaskan alaska city yeah i know
i know that thing probably was in alaska
quite some time ago
if you catch my drink got it it took a
minute to get sick
he was in alaska about seven months ago
he was swimming
freely in alaska about a year ago
so papa bear this weekend yeah we ate
the [ __ ] out of him bruh
six a night i would have touched in that
that
that second show on friday was crunk wow
was it the second how's the chatty kathy
oh you know telling the story about the
white guy that came to you
yeah because you got some nerve buddy
kicking us
out of here i'm like i was watching your
stuff like why this father kicking him
i'm like
what he's he has his glasses on older
white guys he has some nerve man
i know why he goes you're kicking ass
cause we laughing i go
i'm not kicking out yours you had a
security are you what i'm not ahead of
security
and he takes his glasses off and i see
you recognize me and goes
ah [ __ ] hey man get us back it's your
show
i
y'all are great man y'all funny but this
club is [ __ ]
yeah and then one of them stayed one
whole squad got kicked out and then one
of them was like he called his lawyer he
called his lawyer that was the guy who i
was talking to
oh wow oh really he was like you gotta
get us back in man they're kicking us
out for laughing and i was like
you were doing more than laughing man i
was listening back here your whole
[ __ ]
family was yelling at the stage yeah
he's like but we're back here i'm like
everybody can hear it man everybody yeah
everybody got
some nerve i love how he came up to you
got some nerve
buckle yes bucco he said he hit you with
the bucket with the bucket
that sounds like it sounded that's why
he's i mean he looked like a dude that
would say bucko yeah 100
and then we stayed in a dope area but
there was
uh gunshots two other three nights i
think yeah that's how i knew i was back
at home
yeah i feel good two out of three
automatic i was like oh let's go to
7-eleven then we heard
i was like he was still trying to go to
7-eleven they wasn't shooting at us
i mean a lot of people told us because
uh when i what was it called oakland oak
cliff art district
a lot of people like just stay in your
area don't go outside that
like that block we were walking we were
walking though we mean we walked
into taco bell place a little dicey
yeah yeah i didn't know it was dicey she
had a attitude she was working by
herself it was
lovely attitude was bro we was out there
for a long time just sitting on the
parking lot
i was like yo if somebody would have had
a drive-by shooting here to hit all of
us
that's how it was yeah it was like
poisonous
chilling in boys in the hood in that
parking lot yeah yeah oh yeah just like
that
what the [ __ ] man
that hit brittany out and then went back
to the airbnb and throwing like air
punches like trailers
oh yeah yeah air punches yup that's the
best scene
he started crying he started you know
that's how you know like when you're a
kid
notice how emotional his dad laurence
fisher burns yeah his name is
furious that's his name in the movie is
it really yes
furious experience that's his street
name that's the street that's not a
street name
that's his real name boys in the hood of
course i love that movie yeah that's a
great film i wanted to get an impala
after after watching that movie
like more than boys i like men's society
more than boy than the whole time
you don't eat this burger you want this
burger
crazy y'all come on man i'll suck yo
dick what you saying
what you saying i was like over some
head
yeah look at it there it is yeah there
it is i did it perfectly
there you go
she's so fun she's got the braids and
stuff the old the old g homie is always
trying to [ __ ] her
man they have yeah yeah yeah yep it was
his ass
yeah she's so funny damn all right kids
let's take a little break from the chaos
and let's talk about
week five of the nfl
make money and bet on your favorite
games your favorite teams using
draftkings sportsbook
america's top rated sportsbook app
there's ufc this weekend there's ufc
next weekend
gfc 254 you can bet on all of it you bet
on football
monday night football thursday night
football sunday football
with draftkings sportsbook and draftking
sportsbook is giving all new users the
chance to receive
a sign up bonus up to one thousand
dollars on top of that great sign up
offer
draftking offers great odds boost every
sunday help you make it rain
don't worry football is in for you
draftkings giving all you basketball
fans
a 200 percent profit boost on any
basketball market once you sign up
draftkings is safe reliable and secure
making it easy for your deposit withdraw
your money
whenever you feel like it download the
top rate draftking sportsbook app now
use the promo code fighter
when you sign up and get up to one
thousand dollars the code
fighter to get a sign up bonus up to one
thousand dollars for limited time only
after draft king sportsbook must be 21
and older
new jersey indiana pennsylvania only
bonus comprises the first deposit bonus
the first bet match each up to 500
deposit bonus quest 25 playthrough
restrictions apply see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details gambling problem
call when heard gambler or in indiana
189 with it
2020 has been tough but don't make it
tough on you nuts
thanks to manscaped they're on a mission
to take care of your manhood with their
below the waist grooming
hygiene products and great news uk can
australia they're releasing the products
there for you guys so hairy folks down
there
down under we're getting taken care of
they got the crop care kit the crop
preserver
ball deodorant crop reviver clap
cleanser crop mop
ball wipes foot duster for stanky feet
and then not to mention the lawnmower
3.0
world famous trimmer all right the
waterproof technology allows you to
groom in the shower for up to 90 minutes
listen if it takes you 90 minutes you
got something else wrong
and it also has a light on it so you can
do it at night do it in the shower in
the dark get weird all right
get 20 off and free shipping at
manscape.com with the code
fighter 20. if you care for those
beautiful balls of yours all you have to
do is go to their site
hit a few buttons on your phone and you
will change your life for the better
get 20 off and free shipping at
manscape.com with the code
fighter 20 and some swag to your saggy
bag
oh disease
[Applause]
like he's trying to throw up a gang sign
the keys i
i can't believe you guys missed these
things i didn't see it yeah
oh this damn bro you know well he did
play oj he was so good in that he was
great yeah i thought he was oj i thought
he was oj i got to see it
and he looks nothing like o.j but he
great acting listen i thought he was o.j
i look at him i gotta check that out is
that him that's him howard is a cubic uh
goodie
probably like in his 50s oh has to be in
his 50s i mean yeah he did play jerry
maguire
he was great now quit killed it i've
never seen that either
he was good in radio oh i've seen radio
i loved racing
can we honor me that's why i was going
to
go
mississippi that was awesome men of
honor was great
yeah i love look at him in radio bro he
killed that radio he killed it bro
he was too perfect yeah it was good i
want both
i think that's what he said something
like that
why do you do why do you go so hard what
are your daddy what do you say this is
movies
to be the best yeah he's a beast of an
actor he is radio jim mcgregor men of
honor come on
oh boat trip was the funniest movie ever
when he went on a game
with
snow dogs no dogs yeah shout out to snow
it's great as good as it gets
i didn't see that red tails about the
airplane they thought they were gonna
name the washington redskins uh
washington red tails is that a good one
that's one of the options it'd be dope
daddy daycare it wasn't better than oh
he's great an american gangster
oh yeah he is an american gangster i
don't know racist
i thought he was going to win right now
he's been uh coming to america most
people don't know that
he's getting his haircut when they first
go to the to the barber shop
cuba young acting cuba is uh in a barber
shop
he has no lines he's just sitting there
damn he's had some misses though hasn't
he
i saw life his life as a king on netflix
gladiator
the hit list hard pass i know a lot of
these are hard packs yeah this is
home on the range like i said end game
it's been dicey guys
losing isaiah come on a great movie but
i know he was in there
dirty yeah starting to get a little
weird yeah yeah i could say now now he's
just trying to pay the bills
now he's trying to pay them away yeah oh
that oj character saved him he brought
him back oh he's disabled
you got to check that out bro awful
movies
when we talk about malik uh coming to
america coming to the american scene
yeah he's in there
you'll see him he's he's he doesn't have
any like it's the only
scene he's in watch you'll see
right there oh
that's eddie murphy too man oh [ __ ] yeah
yep i found that out like four years ago
he wants to change it too damn it's good
eddie murphy is beast hands down he's in
my
he's in my top three for uh favorite
comedian better be
yeah i love that hilarious yeah how
about that's going to the barbershop and
that's how he was in a real barber shop
oh yeah
when a guy you have a conversation
getting your hair cut and he keeps
having a conversation
that's that's the same way like tattoo
artists are the same way
oh yeah y'all got tatted yeah
what's our boy's name you remember jesse
jessica what's his instagram man
i put in my instagram story i forget he
was great dude
great tattoo artist yeah great artist
yeah
i've seen you picture him and i'm not
making fun of jesse
it just is what it is anytime you got a
tattoo you're doing a podcast
it is true that is a life story true
life
true life you're eating a full [ __ ]
rundown you ever like have like put your
headphones in and you just be bad
jamming you try to talk
like all the halftime oh okay all the
time
i'm like yo what am i going to do with
this information instagram
uh we had that we had it is it on my
story
yeah so it's j e underscore and three
c's
jake underscores three c's yeah let me
go through this real quick though
he's really really no i wouldn't be on
there because it's from the weekend
yeah cops and babies cops and babies
and babies both my father-in-law oh yeah
what's up bro oh yeah you came on this
one with donuts oh jay you underscored
the three c's cops
yeah that's him right there that's him
get free donuts right
yeah usually his work is good
so he him like a couple of a couple of
artists like had hit me up in my dm
he would hit up every city we go to oh
yeah people want to do
tattoos on me i thought it was like fake
i was like is that a serious thing but
but i kept getting uh quite a few of
them that's a dope and he was like yeah
let me tattoo you and brendan and i was
like okay
he's ready uh brent and i looked at his
work
dude came through he came through clutch
man i sent you mine
okay um yeah look at his stuff dude he's
really really good
jay got one yeah dude was great he was
light-handed like like it didn't even it
wasn't even painful yeah he's really
[ __ ] talented
yeah he's from cali i told him he's out
here i'd be about to look like travis
parker in this [ __ ] oh dude he's
he's that like uh that lion
i really thought that was faster i
really thought it was more possible
one day you would lead over the promised
land
anything the light touches okay okay is
yours he's talented it's funny talented
as [ __ ]
dude shout outs out to you but it
doesn't matter who it is it's not him or
a barber you're getting the full
[ __ ] oh you're getting the life story
yeah livestream and then after they tell
you their life story what are we
supposed to do with this information
yeah and i'm like then it usually goes
to sports or weather
that's my that's mine right there man oh
you posted yours no i didn't it's a
chance
that's what i got oh damn it's an oasis
song
so that's the oasis logo but it usually
says oasis in it but
i put one of my favorite oasis songs in
it you got a great schemer
i know that's what he said he said you
got good skin you got great skin yeah i
was like i appreciate that it's like
you know it's a good little melody i
just washed with cast style soap
justin got a tattoo yeah
yeah your brother got the uh checkered
flags checkers
and you got the texas uh symbol look at
this texas logo the skull
skull is badass man he's a good dude
i told him yeah i was like bro anytime i
come to texas you're the you're the man
100
they love you down there in texas bro
that's my that's that's my [ __ ] that's
why you get the tattoo
because you love you really love this oh
texas dude i love sex i always say
one of my favorite one of my favorite
states that i've lived in is texas i
think
that's why i shoot my next special
probably oh dude the crowds for comedy
there oh my god
every night they were electric dude
right they were shouting out stuff out
before you two near me not to hear me
well
i just got there i just got
your uncle probably like me i've heard
that [ __ ] yeah
he was like bro i saw your youtube video
my uncle hit me with like yo i see y'all
on youtube hear me i swear to god he was
like bro i gave you you know i gave it a
thumbs up 7 up
thumbs up
just say you liked it i like that one
it's fun being back up it's it is a
little weird like we don't get to do it
that often and then
an hour when i haven't done stamp in
seven weeks yeah
you beast it though yeah
uh did you see just change subjects did
you see what rogan posted
you know how you know he's getting
shipped
i love that he's doing this he's people
giving [ __ ] you know the spotify
thing and all this and they're trying to
cancel him go to what he posted first of
all this guy's hilarious
instagram uh pretty sure it's instagram
it's a video maybe to
keep going maybe he took it down oh
watch the video
by the way look at my face you know what
maybe it's twitter twitter
have to be twitter probably retweet
hello twitter world hello twitter world
um it's about the spotify
oh there it is it's so [ __ ] yeah
so so pause it for a second so spotify
has a group within their uh
place of business that want to cancel
rogan they want to censor rogan shows
the lgbqt community it's probably like
300 people missed them
but they wanna it's something i don't
know it's okay
i thought you might say lmnop yeah so
they want to cancel him right but it's
when you're looking at how big that that
business is it's a small percentage
okay but they're upset and they want to
censor joe rogan's podcast but they're
loud
they're the loudest on social media so
everyone's saying oh my god everyone
wants to cancel
uh joe rogan no not everyone's canceled
joe rogan the company's
went from a bill when they signed them
it hit a billion
now they're worth 1.6 billion so they're
not gonna so whatever they do they're
not gonna let
go of joe rogan okay but they're the the
minority but they're very loud
and people think it's a bigger deal than
it is so it's all over right now oh so
this guy i don't think he's comedian
yeah he is he's [ __ ] that redhead
dude
is he yeah he is he's funny he towards
us he's great
watch this as spotify employees we're
demanding the executives allow us to
edit
this buddy i know some
[Laughter]
[Applause]
i was just about to say that you stupid
it's about how he likes trans people
which means he doesn't love trans people
which means he hates trans people this
is so spot-on
built a massive audience because people
enjoy and respect what he and his guests
have to say
but who knows better than his audience
what they want to hear we do
but luckily here in the sjw yeah it is
for them
because we're highly intelligent people
well kind of i identify as a cat
but the executives cater to our demands
it's almost like they value a hundred
million dollar asset more than a forty
nine thousand dollar
asset these high-level business
executives just don't know how to do
business
i mean do a lot of people listen to joe
rogan's podcast yes
but what even more people listen to a
heavily censored version of that same
podcast
heavily censored version me also yes
jill rogan cannot be broadcast talking
about the following
trans issues
sex with men which makes him homophobic
racial issues
because he's always having his black
friends on his show and giving them
massive publicity and help for their
careers which he only does because he's
white and he feels guilty about being
white as he should
this most real video on youtube wow
that's
so funny i'm a vegan dmt because it's a
drug and i only take adderall
to people who can't think comedy because
it's hateful to people who aren't
funny how caitlyn jenner killed somebody
with their car because i don't want to
believe that it's true
having open-minded conversations and
exploring new ideas
that's very dangerous and super
close-minded it's not how you learn
it's like the old wisdom that says
letting the inmates
run the asylum is always a good idea are
you listening to me spotify executives
i have to use my litter box now
the only reason he hunts elk is because
he thinks elk are actually trans women
which makes him hateful joe rogan is
yeah i appreciate you asking
i actually shut
so i got mad at the refs for pushing an
impressive narrative look how that pinky
is just so straight
so i quit because i couldn't stand being
around illogical referees who are
pushing a false narrative
and oppressing people that they had
control over because they had a whistle
they were ruining the game of basketball
so anyway
if i don't get my way here at spotify
i'm walking out
[Music]
the executives refused to clean his
litter box
joe rogan stepped and pooped in my foot
we have to stop this monster in joe
rogan's own words that i'm putting into
his mouth
he hates all people who don't have
kettlebell calluses on their head
kettlebell callus
pressure on the spot watch this they
have an outtake of him going
sensor joe rogan then we'll be happy to
work towards censoring your music
and then burning your books because with
spotify employees not only do we know
what's best
but we also care wow
or we are walking out
[Laughter]
one more thing you weird stop it okay i
forget his name though
that's how you deal with haters how
great is that great yeah yeah
it's so great so spotlight it is it's
wild man how you deal with haters
i mean i mean if i hate something i just
don't pay attention to it
well that's a little different than
haters because the these these people
are you know they're loud and they they
don't like what
rogan represents you know does he
represent
men men like you know successful
alpha males you know they think shout
out to they don't want to give them a
platform
so they they think by censoring his
podcast is the way to do it
and they're going to walk out if spotify
doesn't do it you know what spotify is
going to say
there's the door wow yeah they're not
going to
you just can't jp sears there you go jp
thank you that was going to love me
there's another really funny video about
uh
l.a how terrible it is to live in l.a
but he acts like it's all good
it's so funny that's hilarious he's
crashing it man yeah
no he's he's good dude but he was spot
[ __ ] on with that man
man i didn't know it was like that damn
how do you guys
not see it
the first thing i do when i wake up is
read a book oh what else
and then i journey keep going no you see
no news
no like the debates nothing no i saw the
debates oh she was [ __ ] i was
about sports of course you got to watch
for first time
sports no cause i don't i don't have the
you got i got to pay extra if i want to
watch
damn uh sports you know why are you how
are you
what is this well because i'm pointing
at my tv because my tv is above oh and
i'm thinking
something shout out to mountains
streaming services what do you have
i have hulu i have youtube modifying
netflix
netflix come on that's my girls netflix
uh
other ones are mine uh what else i got
don't you hate when you have you know on
somebody else's netflix account and they
don't pay their bill you like yo
oh my gosh yeah that's so cheap ass
doing yes you ain't got 12 hours trying
to cancel it bro
don't do that but i thought netflix cut
that out where you can't share accounts
anymore
they're like they're shutting you can't
wait wait i think they give them
multiple accounts
they're making it tougher to share it
though there's like a limit now mm-hmm
oh so yeah
they trying to make it like it's a game
you gotta feeling it once you get in you
gotta die out i don't like that yeah no
no netflix relax relax relax no but yeah
yeah i don't know what i mean you don't
see the news huh mm-hmm
probably better i'm so i'm so far behind
on that [ __ ] oh we got matt best yeah
matt best is gonna be calling real soon
all right
who matt best ceo of black raffle coffee
ceo co-founder or something like that
yeah i'd say owner
okay where's he at he's a special forces
dude he's in texas
he's coming here right now did he come
to the show no he's in uh
he's in san antonio so he's like three
hours three hours
zoom look so great well because we're
professionals
and he's also yeah he set it up right
well i got my black magic cinematic
pocket pro
i got my sure 7b so you know i'm ready
man
here let's go damn dog oh [ __ ] matt bath
ladies and gentlemen you're looking
freaking you're looking great man what
is it moisturizer what's going on out
there
freedom maybe in texas it's a lot of
freedom and text did we just go
live i like it let's go sorry i'm sorry
that came in hot
dude yeah you look great i gotta assume
it's the freedom
it's the cool set the backdrop back
there what's going on man
it's good you know i got the guitars in
the backdrop i got my 50 cal just
chilling
uh life's good brother every single day
just try to live it up that's what i'm
doing
i was just in uh bug i was in dallas
over the weekend doing shows out there
and i went firing some guns
and uh thought of you because i felt so
goddamn free out there
because i'm i'm in north korea right now
i'm in north korea akla
and uh we're still locked down here and
i'm jealous of all my buddies like you
and tim kennedy and colin uh noir all
those guys man it's just
it's just you guys are doing it right
out there yeah i saw you with coolion
uh man i love that guy he's such a great
advocate for the community and he's just
a rad dude um so it's hard not to like
him
i didn't know i felt stupid i didn't
know he doesn't have any
uh background in uh military background
i thought he was
i don't you know i guess because you
guys are all such gun
advocates i figured most gun advocates
have like a military background or
policing background so i
i thought he was and i was talking about
something and luckily i didn't put my
foot too far down my mouth because
he was like oh i was a lawyer and i was
working on the second amendment and then
i just got really into it and started
firing guns man
i was like oh damn yeah you're really
good at this well i think it's a cool
perspective on that side of the house
because he isn't a veteran but he is
such a supporter of the constitution the
second amendment and he comes from a
very educated background
that it's a good stance to show that hey
you can be a professional and be a great
responsible fireman
firearm owner and not have to be in the
military you know so
i love what he's doing over there cool
cat yeah great dude man
and uh what have you been up to man how
is the uh the pandemic kind of affected
all the stuff you do
and you do a million things yeah i mean
i'm insane super busy uh the pandemic
interestingly enough wasn't that bad
from a personal
behavioral way because uh
you haven't been to my actual personal
house but i live out in the middle of
nowhere i got you know
over seven acres i hunt so i had like
400 pounds of deer meat
i got guns and ammo like i'm set up for
the apocalypse essentially so
when all this went down we had already
kind of from the black rifle side had
it set up for our different headquarters
throughout the united states so
really it was just hey everybody's kind
of working from home and i'm sure
on an individual level people set up
their setups a little differently but
we were pretty set up for it so we were
very thankful for that
um because it wasn't very life-changing
and i know it's impacted a lot of other
people significantly worse
yeah did it affect black rifle as far as
the headquarters and like coffee
delivery or did delay the deliveries or
anything
no if any delays really came out of that
it was either the postal service
or that function because they got so
inundated with you know
orders and everybody shopping online but
we got ahead of it really early when
everybody's like ah it's not that big of
a deal we put in the you know procedures
to make sure that the plants are super
clean and healthy and keeping the
employees that have to be their roasting
coffee super healthy so
we got very fortunate and you know the
majority of our business
is e-commerce and online and so
it kind of worked out for us from from
that standpoint
yeah you just so you just been doing the
damn thing life as usual on your ranch
just killing [ __ ] and kind of hanging
out
dude just been working it's been crazy
we've been in production with
commercials and uh
you know we just opened last weekend a
new black rifle
uh standalone store so it's the
drive-through and everything and where's
that grand opening
san antonio so it was their first
standalone corporate uh store it was a
pretty cool moment
in a lot of years in the making congrats
man i didn't know that
yeah thank you we would have had a
bigger party invited people down but
obviously we had restrictions as far as
how many people could be there
and then you said you've been in uh
shooting production what what are you
guys shooting
just commercials you know q4 we're
getting ready to do all of our sale
stuff and all that coming up and so you
know us we're always making some
[ __ ] ridiculous ass commercials [ __ ]
have nothing to do with coffee but then
we sell coffee
yeah sales got people like oh they blew
up a prius i'm gonna
buy that dark roast like they did this
thing
yeah they did this thing where they
launched the prius and [ __ ]
shot it what'd you guys shoot it with
well without the shooting ones there but
we we
put a a minigun from an aircraft on top
of a prius
and had a mini gun on a prius because
why not you know
why we're like little kids sometimes
where we think of these stupid ideas
around a glass of whiskey like we should
put a minigun
on a prius and then we just do it we're
watching the video right now it looks so
dope
yeah who comes up with the ideas and
then someone like what's the budget on
this thing
like there's no way you guys are hitting
budgets
it's not as much as you think we we were
lucky on that one at least to work with
uh battlefield vegas which is a awesome
kind of
uh shooting facility in las vegas they
had that
weaponry and we worked through some of
the licensing and the things you have to
do to get it functioning
and then we just built the chassis on
the prius we bought the used prius for
like six thousand dollars so i mean
relatively it wasn't that expensive
the project took 160 man hours damn it
looks pretty dope man
you guys been doing it right though
because you you started out in
uh your headquarters which are still
there but you're not there you guys
we're in
salt lake city right utah
yeah we still have a big present in salt
lake's presence in salt lake city and
then
we have one of the corporate
headquarters here in texas where i'm
based out of and then our tennessee
facility so we're kind of all over
yeah you're all over and so you guys i'm
assuming right now you're not shooting
like new rap videos or anything
which i love i'm such a bad [ __ ]
rapper that i don't think i'm gonna
touch that anymore i think oh i'm so
fun though man i'm gonna start by a fake
country career i've been working on that
one yeah
that'd be really dope are you guys still
doing the the podcast you guys chill out
on that
i remember you talking about chilling
out on that for a second
uh we actually walked away from our old
podcast someone say walked away but we
have
a different host now and then we have
one internal on our side free range of
americans so you're welcome to come on
anytime but we've had some great guests
on there and
um that's more black rifle specific
internal podcast
so it's been a really fun we've got some
amazing guests on and there's
you know podcasting is fun because
you're going to meet really cool people
usually unless i'm on your show and then
you start [ __ ] my dumb ass but
get out of here man so what so what's
2021 looking for for you is you you
excited about you anything
crazy going on it's just business as
usual man
uh yeah business is usual man but it's
it's pretty cool it's exciting things
not just talk about the company but
that's my you know 80 hours a week right
there
on it we got you know ready to drink
options coming out so like canned coffee
we're getting convenience stores
7-elevens and walmart
and we're working on our brick and
mortar retail roll out so we're
uh you know kind of proof of concept the
last one there in uh san antonio we're
starting to open those up nationally
and getting our franchise program worked
on to hire
like we talked about how many veterans
we want to hire and then all the
non-profit side so we're just
we're staying busy the good thing is we
love to work so we're just trying to
crush it
i mean it can't be long before somebody
makes a huge offer and just buys you
guys out let's be real here
and then you're going to be the elon
musk of veterans don't you think
you know what i'm saying like that's the
path you're headed down
uh yeah you know i i wouldn't say that
that
could be an option but i severely doubt
you know um like evan and i we don't
really want to
sell the company we love what we're
doing and i think the company's
successful because we're authentic
about what we want to do and then what
we support and i think if you had
some big holding company you know by 100
of the company and you have no
voting power and you can't guide the
brand then they're essentially just
going to crunch numbers
lose the essence of the brand and it
[ __ ] dies
it'd be terrible to ever see that so i
severely doubt we'll ever go down that
path
well yeah hopefully spotify didn't bite
um
we actually just thought rogan evan and
i went up there and uh
and uh did his show last week that was
cool oh did you guys had to go
like great i think i just kind of like
slipped in there because i just showed
up with evan and then joe was like hey
jump on the show i was like all right
you know and who
i can't believe you and uh rogan haven't
met before
i can't believe he hasn't on you uh solo
before
oh yeah i do i'm sure a guy like that's
so hyper requested i mean i'm a nobody
but i mean i've met him a few times
in passing and then at the store but
yeah but we're friends
we're boys you're on you've been on this
show a number of times
rogan [ __ ] with black rifle obviously i
[ __ ] with black rifle
i think that's why he had a had a son it
just you know we're all scared all
yeah that's true so you drove down to
austin you get did you guys
shoot or kill anything afterwards
unfortunately no but we were actually
all of us
uh we were a little couple days after
him we're up in utah elk hunting
and so everybody got their their elk up
there and now it's time to get the back
straps and throw them on the barbecue i
mean
if you want to invite to come back to
texas you let me know i got
i got thick boy food waiting for you bro
i'll don't don't tempt me i'll look for
any excuse to get to texas especially
right now dude the relocation of people
right now
is absolutely [ __ ] insane i mean
all the houses in this area and like the
five plus acres are getting bought up
you're having transpose from
la and cali coming out here i mean it's
it's i think everybody's in that kind of
field of thought that wait everything's
kind of conditioned to be vtc
and internet based now rather than
events so and i travel for events
and so i think that's this thing is
going to shape the future of america and
business
for like forever i don't think it's ever
going to go back to
how it was before but and i think for
the better man i really do i think for
the better
but what i what i find interesting i
shouldn't say funny what i find
interesting
is so many people are moving to austin
right but joe roger all these people
and i'm just not i'm not picking on
rogan in particular but so many people
that we know our buddies and our circle
so many people are moving to austin and
like yeah forget la
there's such a democratic liberal state
i'm moving to austin i'm like have you
been to austin
it's pretty liberal man it's pretty yeah
it's boulder
but with guns you know what i'm saying
like it's pretty little boulder
yeah well that's like a kind of a fear
of mine and not to be a tin hat where
but it seems that there's a lot of
people that had this
um belief system as far as how
taxation and economic should work and
then it
they were in a failed state and failed
govern state however from a municipality
level or whatever up to the to the whole
state but
then they leave and they bring that kind
of same economic
uh ideology to a properly run city i'm
like
hey maybe this is a learning lesson
where you don't bring your [ __ ] out
to us
and i'm not saying like we're perfect or
right but there's a reason that
you know we're not like a bunch of debt
right like our state so correct
maybe like [ __ ] off a little bit please
yeah it's a little weird right it's like
how would you why would you bring the
same mentality that caused
you know the ruins in l.a over to texas
like the oxy didn't work man
so if you're just moving over here if
enough of you move over here
you're just gonna shape the ideology
over there it's gonna be a [ __ ] [ __ ]
show
but you guys maybe the silver lining is
will legalize wheat in texas finally you
know
uh other other than that you know i
think some people look at conservative
states as
oh they're so right-wing and then they
get to meet us they're like i don't care
who you [ __ ] i think it's great like
smoke weed like
you know don't take all my taxpayer
money and burn it
that's kind of what i don't want you to
do yeah i can't believe
uh weed isn't legal in texas yet
come on it's the only knock on texas
really
it is you know and i don't think it's
it's not the people's fault necessarily
i think it's more of all the lobbyists
you have with the tobacco industry and
the alcohol industry
and it's more of a industries yeah oh
100
you have millions and gazillions of
dollars getting dumped into
anti-lobbyists for marijuana is because
they don't want to get legalized because
people will wean themselves off alcohol
and opioids and be smoking weed and
laughing their ass off rather than
taking antidepressants every day and
i think that scares a lot of people that
are not vested in the american public's
health but they're vested in how much
money they can [ __ ] buy so they can
get their 19th yacht and you're like
come on man
yeah let the homies smoke some weed
together or at least decriminalize it
you're right man did you i don't know if
you've talked about this
in your book you mentioned a little bit
how other guys suffer with it but
did you when you were done with your
service did you did you have any issues
with
uh alcohol or drugs or anything which a
lot of guys do right
a lot of athletes do yeah i was a
terrible alcoholic when i got in the
military terrible i was drinking
a whole bottle a night to sleep i mean
i'm already an insomniac but
i think portions of that were associated
with being so kind of ostracized from
the community that you knew
and you didn't feel like you get along
with anybody as far as how you think
about life
and then you immediately turn to
self-medication and the most viable
option there unless the va gives you a
bunch of
like oxycodones is alcohol and then you
become reliant on it it's a very
addictive substance
and there's no moderation and so it took
me a while to work through that for sure
and you see that happen a lot within our
community of people coming out
moving back to their hometowns feeling
completely left out from the culture
there and they just hit the bottle hit
the bottle
and that spirals everything into this
downward you know movement of
losing their job having relationship
problems and they're all compounded
based off the fact that
they're addicted to a substance and
that's why i'm very involved
um there's a there's a non-profit here
it's called the warriors heart
foundation
and it's the only substance addiction
rehabilitation center for law
enforcement veterans only
and they treat them like people and i
sit on their honorary board of advisors
but that's what we're working for is
these guys have ruined their life
pulling them in getting them sober and
then push them over to other
organizations that i work for
like the boot campaign where we get them
blood work we get them
uh you know brain scans and then you
know they're getting diagnosed at the va
that they have
pts and we find out that no they got
blown up in a vehicle
and they have 40 memory loss you know
short-term memory loss and so now we
know
we can put them through cognitive
therapy and actually
get them a good life again rather than
you know putting a band-aid on a bullet
hole like they're going to bleed out
eventually
yeah yeah i think what's interesting too
is
you know everyone says you know ptsd you
know with
with veterans stuff like that and you
tell me if i'm way off on this map but
like
i think it's similar to as far as you
know when
how it relates to athletes it's like if
you're an athlete and you've dedicated
your life to sports
let's say you make the nfl you're one of
the few lucky ones who make the nfl you
have a six-year career
all you've been doing your entire life
from that moment since you were seven
years old
to let's say you're 29 is commit to
football
and you have this strict regiment you
have a strict schedule you know what
you're going into
you identify as a football player and
then when you have to retire due to
injury or whatever they tell you're not
good enough you gotta retire
well then you get done and it's like all
that attention
the the the kind of friendships you've
created
this circle that you've you know you've
been used to for the past
20 something years that's not there
anymore so a lot of these guys they
they don't know what they're going to do
they have a certain skill set they don't
know what they're going to do they're
lost
you know they they start drinking and
doing drugs and stuff like that
but i know it's not similar because i've
seen it on war and there's not ptsd but
there's ct
there's just that kind of they don't
feel like they belong anymore but and so
i feel like
not it only doesn't only affect veterans
but it affects kind of that
that group you know that where you're
you've been known as something for so
long when you're done with it
i feel like that's where the depression
a lot of that comes from
i couldn't agree more i mean humans are
innately massively tribal
right and so you see that in any kind of
clique whether it was a fraternity and
you know guys like those are the best
days of my life it's because they're
around
a tight-knit group of friends and they
thought alike they ate the same [ __ ]
they drank the same [ __ ]
and then you're pulled out of that into
a completely different culture it's hard
to assimilate whether you are
a sports athlete or or a veteran and i
think there's a large portion of the
veteran community that
suffers from that but that's why we
create outreach programs and hopefully
companies like ours where you can
easily assimilate back into it and i
mean you even see that in the [ __ ]
mma community right
guys that shouldn't be fighting anymore
but they just don't know how to put up
the gloves
and they used to be legends and you're
like man
please like do something else because i
don't want to see you walking around
stumbling every sentence like
save your brain go go find another path
or journey and be happy
please just don't like but it's your
body yep to your point with fighting
it's like those guys
even have less resources because they
get done there's no 401k there's no
benefits there's nothing
so they get done it's like all right i
guess i'll go work for a ufc gym
you know what i'm saying to make 20
grand of [ __ ] years it's like there's
no options
so then they're like oh he has ct i'm
like
oh he's just [ __ ] depressed dude he
used to be on main events
knocking dudes out he's getting all this
attention making
a decent living but he can't retire and
ride off in the sunset
and now that's over and they can't use
his body anymore and he has to go figure
life out and it's [ __ ] tough man
it's tough for college kids who do five
years at
freaking ucla and they get done and you
know if their dad doesn't own a business
give him a job right away
they're [ __ ] lost man they're trying
to figure out you know everyone has that
law period where they're you know
they're they're lost
i'd be interested because i don't know
off the top of my head but if i was like
a board member an executive in like an
organization like the ufc
you would think that they would like
allocate at least resources internally
while fighters are doing well like
financial planning and savings because a
lot of those guys and gals i mean i'm
sure they started fighting at five years
old in the dream to be on a main card
one day and they get it and that
what's the what's the shelf life for
that two or three years on average if
i mean it's yeah it used to be the
average career used to be a year and a
half
and then now i think it's it's a little
higher than that probably two two and a
half years
because everyone sees you know the
connors or the
the khabib's and they think that that's
everybody but there's dudes on those
prelims or
in and out dude in and out you know yeah
and then also
you know not everybody's conor mcgregor
so he could retire never work again
most guys you know they'd be better off
working at starbucks they probably make
a similar
paycheck but they have benefits that
that's the real shame of all of it
yeah and there and those those connors
and khabibs are anomalies really i mean
even guys like i don't know if you saw
like cody garbrandt like he was getting
ready to fight pour his bicep
and i just tore my bicep and i i'm like
i feel so bad for that guy because it is
a [ __ ] [ __ ] show of recovery it's not
painful it's just
that's what i said on below the belt i
said you know he he was like oh i'll
fight in december i was like there's no
way that dude would be ready to fight in
the summer if it's
my born bicep i tore my bicep july 5th
i tore mine and i'm two and a half
months out from surgery
i still can't lift 10 pounds with my arm
yeah [ __ ]
and there are more worse injuries out
there but like those ligament ones and
what they do to your bone like it's
you're
you're out for a long time to even get
back like yeah starting again
yeah god god willing hopefully comes
back stronger but
you know dana said it best too you know
when people ask him about
you know fighter pay and benefits and
all this he goes
listen fighting's not a career it's an
opportunity
and when you hear the captain the ship
go yeah man it's opportunity
so hopefully you're a conor mcgregor but
most you aren't gonna be it's just an
opportunity
i'm giving the opportunity if it works
out great if it doesn't you gotta figure
it out
so i think by him saying that and him
being truthful which
i think people should give him credit
for that should carry a lot of weight
where the fighters mentality go oh
not only am i going to fight but i kind
of got a lunch of their [ __ ] up and you
see guys doing that like
sugar shawn o'malley's do did that yeah
um you know you look at people
on twitch you see that like [ __ ] who's
still doing a firefighter job and those
fires he bounced and went i was like man
that's
and that dude's the you know the
champion making a pretty good
fight purse but look at connor look at
connor look at connor connor goes on my
launches whiskey
i'm gonna launch you know my own media
line you know uh so
mac life like you know a lot of these
guys figure it out man because they they
realize yeah it is an opportunity
because when you hear the head guy say
that you can like oh [ __ ] but it's the
most real thing i think
dana white's ever said i think there's a
lot of parallels between that style the
prize fighting and like the whole new
influencer movement because a lot of
these
influencers they don't have really
talents they're just you know
attractive or found a niche audience and
their shelf life is like one to three
years
and they went from making no money to
like thousands or hundreds of thousands
of dollars in some cases and then one
day it just goes away when the new fad
comes in and they're like
but i'm me you know and thankfully like
i've had a little bit of a run but
that's always why i went into business
was like
i'm not gonna be like the face of the
camera for
[ __ ] 20 years i'll get some gray
hairs and people like no one wants to
watch this fat best dude
but it's also exhausting to be that guy
you have to
reinvent yourself all the goddamn time
you know and years later and come up
with content all the time like
sometimes it's it's good to be the the
businessman you know
you can only do so many tick tock dances
until you're like that shit's stupid go
to an actual dance studio
what is this i know they're just trying
to go viral bro
that's it man i mean part of it is
because you know they make probably more
money than i do by dancing in front of
an iphone
and part of it is i think it's just
stupid so yeah there's no longevity in
it though man
well yeah um i wish we could do this in
person man hopefully next time we do
this in person man you know i love you
man and
uh black rifle i stand by you guys all
the time man i say this on every goddamn
read i do for on it though but the
the [ __ ] yeah coffee with the
caffeinated crystals that's that's my
[ __ ] man that's my [ __ ]
and i got problems because i can i can
drink five expresses and go to bed
but that coffee will wake me up it's the
only one that would do it
i appreciate it man bad guys you know we
love you if you're ever in texas feel
free to hit us up and
on the on it know i was just drinking
alpha brain right during this and i have
no stake in the game but
i guess i was taking the game all right
brother well i appreciate you coming on
man be safe out there man i'll talk to
you soon
appreciate it homie thanks hi brother
matt best ladies and gentlemen
thanks thanks dude thanks man cheers
yeah
thanks guys shout out to matt bess man
one of my buddies
my good friend yeah yeah small guy
i was hoping he'd be on rogan for a
while now i didn't know he went on it uh
last week did rogan post
i don't think i would have seen it so
he's delaying the episodes
he's got some pre-recorded maybe yeah
maybe it's hunting or some [ __ ] so he
pre-records them
okay but yeah talking about the
bicep tears the worst tier yeah biceps
bad like cody garbrandt tore it man and
he was like i'll be ready to go in
december there's no
no wait there's no way you now you get
surgery then you get the rehab it'd be
tough that's it you know
why rush it though yeah why rush it like
uh
he's looking at mid next year i'd say
hopefully he's okay yeah if you don't
know obamacare like that's a [ __ ]
[Applause]
shut the [ __ ] up let's do some current
events what do you got jim
all right first of all what's gin got oh
cheers
celebrity to have an only fans account
is tyga
what and unlike other celebrities tyga
actually went
and put like actual nudes on only fans
usually people just kind of dress
scantily clad he put his whole ass dick
on only fans what
no no stop yes he was trending for a
couple of days
somebody screenshot that [ __ ] i have if
you'd like to yes
well hold on is he working what time out
wait time are you working with a thicky
dicky wait wait wait wait we
have the big dicks oh wow let me see if
it has a big dick we don't really want
to see it we should just go on this
camera i want to see it
hang on scroll down wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait
wait timeout
yeah that's why i screenshotted it i
knew you would want to see it glad
yeah how did you see it cat it was
trending on twitter
tiger only fans continue well did you
just send it to the chin yeah so shannon
has to look at it
shane always has points
he was like destroyed already see look
at that he tried to sound destroyed my
computers have been destroyed
so it says
let's uh let's zoom in on this
look at that goddamn popsicle stick hey
look at this
you got a problem dog i'm just comparing
to mine
yo chin give us a one yo no brother
yo yo you make it nasty
make it nasty i just keep seeing that
now there's some other
uh hip-hop artists like cardi b and
other kids
that have done he needs to judge yeah
there's there's famous people
yeah like amber rose is on only fans
blac chyna i think is
the person who makes the most money on
only fans right now um my high school
crush on only only fans
uh a girl we went to her name is raven
um williams
it was 5.99 i subscribed okay she's bad
she's bad yeah
and she's showing everything but you
guys are thinking like it's 5.99 that's
like things like that
well if you're on fan yeah man you crazy
they make them hey
they make it i know they make bank yeah
i know you mean like you can't be going
well
like like drake's like me on only fans
yeah no no the tigers
oh you talking about celebrities oh yeah
why are you on the only thing oh
yeah i'm saying if you're uh a celebrity
with only fans account
you can't be killing another aspect of
course of course of course i got what
you're saying
not like some regular ass person just
getting on it oh yeah was she killing
raven i always wanted i was dreaming of
a body not mad at the two kids i was
happy after two kids yeah
because you know you're a high school
crush you got to wrestle yep i was like
okay you still can get it
interesting good for him i bet posting a
dick pic though he got a bunch more
how many subscribers does he have i have
no idea
we would have to look that up look at
that [ __ ] but
i want to see how much he's making man
you want to know for research purposes
guys
and he can't get in trouble doing it
right no no right cd i love you
subscribe
how do you see how many subscribers they
have i don't know it doesn't show huh
it says likes seven thousand forty seven
posts yeah it's not a lot
maybe you can only see it if you have
access to it damn his his tagline is
like you i don't give a [ __ ] about your
boyfriend
hold on well that's crazy hold on wait
let me go on hers what does it say i
like you
i like you i like you but that's a line
from
um some song that's popular on tick tock
right now
he's doing tick tock quotes too yeah
he's trying to is he doing this
you talk too he does tic tac man i
thought he was killing the game and what
he was doing
he's super thirsty no well
it gets me pretty thirsty yeah that's
pretty thirsty posting a dick pic
i know well let's talk about his dick
real quick if you guys don't mind what
oh
i don't need to talk about it i swear to
god you put that [ __ ]
i'm just serious no [ __ ] now you got
this you coming here with this man that
mask on oh
[Applause]
to me it looks skinny i wonder if it's
because it's so long it looks skinny or
is it just
is it so long
it's long and skinny so it's not great
now listen by the circumference of the
whole the shaft
look at that look at that
look at pikachu you know he's not
posting only fans dick pic if
he wasn't packing some heat yo she said
this girl goes damn [ __ ] be packing
oh my god damn that's a lot that's
aggressive that is for him man
i guess yeah he's making money off of it
man he probably is yeah because you have
to pay for that
it says 20 bucks a month yeah i'm about
to go ahead manscape and put mine on
there
do it what else you guys all right like
okay some people are mad because um
vice came out with an article saying
that twitter will take down
any sort of like comment or tweet that
wishes death upon trump and then they
went and retweeted it
and said that they would take down any
death threats and people just lit them
on fire because they're saying that
they didn't take down like death wishes
or death threats from
like obama or like women on yeah
times have changed so any death threat
they should take down though
uh yes that's whether there's no matter
who it is
gay white black mexican chinese
someone's giving them death threats they
should just ban their account
you know what's gay that picture popping
up they should take that [ __ ] down
hey yeah they should take that down that
was but twitter is one of the last
social media accounts that'll let you
post nudes
that's what i'm saying yeah yeah right
that's crazy but they gotta have like
they just put tigers dangling up that's
what i'm saying well he bought only fans
fans put it up there he didn't put it on
there but you everyone knows he's gonna
screenshot like like
like if you're a news league on the
timeline somebody's gonna screenshot and
put it on
yeah i'm with uh i'm with this person so
many women uh
have been experienced this for a long
time this better applied to them too
from now on
yeah i think they should make it across
the board yeah about death threats
oh look at twitter twitter goes twitter
world uh tweets that wish or hope for
death serious bodily harm or fatal
disease against
anyone are not allowed and will need to
be removed
with danny green that's great and they
go like these and a bunch of these pop
up
like these let's see
uh we gotta bring my glasses him oh
you can't read that we hope obama dies
from
cold are you getting mad at me though i
mean god damn dog that those are
we all hope obama dies from mad cow
disease
damn damn you can die from that
you got a pissed off cow yeah i hope
obama dies oh let me read it
i hope obama died a slow painful death
and uh what's that word can you can't
read that one
i was mad as hell
yeah but they should they should ban
those accounts too yeah yeah
agree but they think that has got to be
accountable for the [ __ ] that pops off
on there
you know what i mean they're going to be
accountable for the like i think all
social media platforms need to start
taking so much yeah
yeah these death threats and the
bullying you guys got dumb [ __ ]
yeah get a life hey stop that get a life
but you don't how do you know if it's a
troll
or or it doesn't matter why would it
matter what do you mean
no i'm just i think if it's a celebrity
or a troll if they tweet some dumb [ __ ]
it should be
you you're right wait what is your i
don't think no no no i'm talking about
how would you know like yo this is just
a buy or a real
like a burner account yeah bots don't do
that yes they do oh my god
yes they do all right listen i like i
said i read books when i wake up
okay good for you yeah i'll try to try
to
i'm already crazy i don't want to be
even crazier you know
i try to just read it twitter and
facebook it's kind of not too bad but
it's like they just
they make so they say one thing they do
another it's like they're so
all over the [ __ ] place mm-hmm no i
didn't know they was getting like death
threats like that oh come on well
i'm not on i'm not yeah yeah
what else you got anybody does anything
they get like says anything
hey anybody with an opinion will get a
death threat
no matter what your viewpoint is you
just got a bunch of losers on it
but clearly yeah i was talking about
like how they was in my
dm my comments they was like yo malik
you suck on the show i was like well
talk that talk
they're they're mean to you yeah but i
was hyping up your comments yeah my
yeah you go through them dms are on like
your posts you do
no on dms in the post both oh dude that
was like bro
right he feeds that energy well i i want
them a little bro malik you suck i'm
like let them know
and then next you know they hype them up
so good they they're bored i'm bored and
then we just
there's some things i don't like but i
would never just go to the [ __ ] page
or something
that i didn't like and just write i
don't like you yeah well yeah but people
are not a loser
because you're doing you're he's doing
stuff creating like just why
just because they have nothing to do
dude so they're just really upset and
it's like
i guess it gives them something to do to
do something it's like that's your
problem
that's why you're a loser because if
you'd take that same energy and put it
towards something positive
you might do something or just something
about yourself you might get something
about you
yeah something about you um
so a couple days ago mgk got blackout
drunk
and he kicked the uh car windshield
out i guess this is his car's friend
they were driving down
hollywood and there were a bunch of
paparazzi who were taking photos
he was so drunk they just started
kicking in the windshield and it came
out then he went on ig live
[Music]
it's okay
so people listen to
uh i pissed in a homie's car when i was
real drunk keep going
um i i'm sorry jeff i did that
right charlie yeah yeah oh yeah because
i asked him to take me to mcdonald's and
he wouldn't
and so i stomped on the roof of his car
and then i i peed in it because his one
of his windows was broke
and so it was just easy that bad i
didn't have i mean
i didn't know what was and then i also
pissed in the corner of his dorm room
when he was out of town so i'm sorry for
that you don't like toilets hey how old
is mgk
he i think he just turned like 31 30.
he's in his 30s
i think he's 30. like very early
megan fox 34 she can't be like oh this
is cool
she has something she has like a whole
family too family
yeah she's got uh three kids three kids
okay relax i know this is possible you
guys haven't seen what's been going on
with her ex
machine gun kelly what's his name brian
brian austin green
that's the producer using 90210
i'm gonna just say it i'm gonna just say
it say it what
is he he's the white guy yeah yeah okay
i think they're all white aren't they on
90210 oh i remember that dude
so that that's that's her ex
what him and mgk are fighting well mgk
kind of went at him and then he
because he posted like yeah i guess do
they have kids together
they yeah they have i think little boys
together
two together and then one is his from a
previous relationship
is he he is quite a bit older than her i
think
like they started dating when she was 18
and he was like in his
30s already really so he's like a bit
older than her yeah yeah she's only a
year older than me i think
yeah that's weird though because she
she's just doing some mommy [ __ ] you
know like she has
kids dude yeah this guy's kicking out
he's like
what what are you doing or what what is
that a crop for help
i don't know i don't know i don't know
what that is some people trying to live
that needs some help though they
try to live that reckless life i mean 30
come on yes
30 30. yeah he died his hair blonde huh
i'm your biggest fan all right i was
like yeah i love that video oh okay
stands tight stan is hard what else you
got all right
disneyland or disney laid off 20 000
employees obviously
who goes to disneyland no one right now
well you can't right now yeah
but before everybody i guess those are
boards there but wait what
what kids you're too as a grown man
just to assault me and assume that i
would go to disneyland by myself
obviously someone drugged me there
[ __ ] your girl
drugged you there yeah you had the magic
kingdom let's talk about it
my ass and i've been to disney world too
plenty of times i get so bored
if you're not fun i'm not funny you're
not fun
place make you happy me and my
girlfriend in there
it's exhausting she said no unless you
have kids i bet you no i understand that
like you need kids yeah if i yeah if i
had a kid obviously it'd be different
but
no it's not brilliant disney theme park
in florida shanghai japan hong kong
have been able to reopen limited
capacity both california invention
disney have remained
shuttered in the anime which is just all
political man
it's [ __ ] crazy
that's not wait china's open oh yeah
they said unlimited
[ __ ] the rest of the world is pretty
much open now have you seen the parties
in wuhan the rest of the world
google that [ __ ] they got parties going
on
[ __ ] lit yo he's he's bringing up
parties and move in
there's other places that are open yeah
i heard the rest of the world is
basically opening back up
wuhan hosts massive pool party wuhan
party shows china's strategic
victory over kovit thousands attend
wuhan pool party let me see this uh-huh
the chinese number [ __ ] are you kidding
me why wouldn't
it oh that ain't real that's it i don't
know i swear to god that that that was
in august
august 15th august 15th yeah how about
okay shawty
and they started it and they're crushing
it they started the virus
what but what about like italy they was
they was down pretty bad see that's a
little bit of news i knew
they're ahead of us what was that bts
okay okay okay just one guy and a girl
how crazy is this and we can we can we
can't have
a [ __ ] crowd at the football game
he's the worst uh they did this weekend
what'd you call it georgia
not in l.a
all we care about yeah what about what
about new york
shut down as well shut down
chicago shut down so all the major
cities never had democrat democrat
democrat okay that's just open fans
driving florida open fans thriving which
i'll be in florida uh
october 15th tampa hollow
is there any limited capacity there or
no
i think that's what it says i think it
still says that on the site i'm not sure
i thought
it's gonna be pretty open you think so
yeah we'll buy a ticket
get a ticket y'all yeah it'll be great
god damn yeah do you guys know wuhan was
lit like this no
no i don't even know who him bro you
watched the news was just on worldstar
no this is just
no this is all over man yeah i did not
know how old is this uh
article well this is august 19th or
august 20th yeah this is where
we do it now you know this is recent
because that guy the security guard is
wearing a mask wait where
him right here he was already wearing
mask outside that's not a mask that's
his face
no i'm telling you this is wrestling
he's wearing a mask they do that i know
i believe it's
all over i believe it's all over so
china is open
damn and they having pool parties by the
way
that's not a pool party no one is i know
there's just water side by side i was
like what is that
it's just fun i like the neon lights
i love how they have one person in the
pool with a floaty
it's like now we turn this [ __ ] there's
coachella isn't that crazy well i mean i
guess it's just so hard for me to pay
attention to because you have
so much arguments on so different sides
and no one's ever like i don't know i
just feel like you don't know what's
going on on the
same page so that's why it's just hard
for me to like that's fair
pay attention cool party already i don't
see people get mad that you don't have a
mess people get
like [ __ ] all these women's full dressed
up at this wuhan pool party what are the
bikinis
what a bikini they had a girl in there
with a snake bruh they know they didn't
have a girl on there with a scarf out of
luck
she should have been back evacuated from
the premises hell no okay
i know right look at this dresses
outfits look at that
[Music]
that's moving
[Music]
uh after pandemic pool party sends a
message to the world strict antivirus
measures have a payback
so they're trying to say since they
locked down so hard now they're back um
they're trying to just shove it in our
faces yeah like what else you got
this right here dr jerry won his legal
battle congrats to him oh damn yeah
congrats to him
and then it said somewhere she was
getting death threats or something too
oh [ __ ] go against the idea why do they
care why do you
why are you waiting after this lady what
is it she has nothing to do with your
life correct
you're gonna send her a death threat
it's very shy because you're a dr dre
fan well he did make the chronic
i get it but still what do you what she
has nothing to do with that you're right
so they say how much he has to pay her
five million for her legal fees
wait wait that ain't nothing he gotta
pay five he has to pay
they're asking dr dre hold on i thought
there was an update to this oh let's see
the update
the judge rejected request okay you're
right yeah yeah
also he there but he still has to pay
her legal fees right some weird thing
with divorces
with the men in california something
like that i think california is like
wild for like divorce a nightmare yeah
yeah you might as well just stay
together
yeah wait so he is he coming out of five
mill out of the pocket or not like
because okay they're trying to figure it
out
is he gonna is he what he's down to give
her something he hasn't he's gonna have
to but her demands weren't it was like
one point something million a month
a month yeah hell no but he's just
probably gonna give her a lump sum and
just like
they're gonna have to figure it out
imagine you spending like 1.5 million to
like on a girl that you don't even want
to have sex anymore but if you're a
billionaire you've been married for 20
years that's a pretty good deal
1.5 million a month he's a billionaire
yeah but nothing that's like that's like
you paying your bill
yeah that's you paying your phone bill
you're going to pay something
because you have kids and you've been
married to this long term they're all
adults though
they're right they're all adults right
now so what does she what is
it doesn't matter you still pay child
support after they're adults no they're
not paying child he's not paying child
support
alimony and divorce what exactly is
alimony
it's i mean look up the complete uh
definition
marlon wayne yeah he said something
about nick diaz what um he said
something about nick diaz
in a good way i think so okay alimony
yeah
alimony yes i'd rather see marlon wings
spousal support so will last half the
length of less than ten years long
however in longer marriages the court
will not set elementary duration the
burden will be on the party who pays to
prove despite the support
it's not necessary at some future point
in time so so
so after 10 years right yeah wait i know
after 10 years you don't have to pay
right is that what they're saying but
for me it's only 18 years they hit you
everywhere maybe for six years to judge
me and let me know the money forever
you're paying either way you're paying
me the weight go go to the marlin
wayne's thing yeah yeah yeah
let me google it real quick i thought
you had it i did you're gonna get
married
no no no i mean yeah because i love his
love
love is tight yeah bro i like it
there's nick diaz right there you saw
that yeah were you asking about like
self-defense and stuff
no no no i i i was old by the way
about to fight them and i said uh bro
you you [ __ ] with the wrong dudes
because [ __ ] that bro you don't know me
oh [ __ ] i said hey i said look at his
ear he's a no
no nick grabbed his ass pop pop three
elbows pop out
two knees the fight was over blood
everywhere eyes i just tapped you to say
i told your ass
he should have said world storm that's
what she was saying
we messed up this video that video yeah
a little short
super old you know what i don't believe
it
and you know what else that never
happened
i heard i knew it wasn't because trust
me we would have heard it in the media
all right so there's plans there's plans
to bring steelhead trout back to the la
river shut the [ __ ]
up seriously this is in the la times
ginzal good news fellas
can you imagine the l.a are you all done
with lies and demise
it's time for some trouble can you
imagine trout in downtown l.a
i brought you the old stuff
listen we're going through the past
present and the future
so let's just put them in the yeah that
whole you know the spillway or whatever
you call it
dude whatever you're gonna destroy those
fish i know
are these they can go fishing this time
yeah where
fishing literally in the la river you
know you see you guys drive by
the freeway fish though you know when
people are pissing and tossing needles
into that it is constantly moving though
so
yeah that's true yeah what yeah so it
should be done by 2028.
well look forward to that trout
okay that's that you know what steelhead
trout are they're like rainbow trout
yeah i have yeah we got them in colorado
man yeah they're awesome
is trout better than salmon you think
different tastes
salmons if you like just delicious fatty
fish salmon's the way to go
like a little more gamey white fish
right yeah it has its own yeah it's a
white flesh it has its own taste
it's hard to describe but it's delicious
did you go camping this past weekend
the weekend before i didn't catch
anything i caught
a baby bass and i caught a few bluegill
but then they got off the hook and then
i caught something else bigger
at the end and then got away all right
yo
i always wonder like i'll be watching
these like fishing like early in the
morning because they come on at five
o'clock when everyone's asleep
yeah and and respect it of course but
i'll watch it and they like have
they'd be out there for a minute and
they have like 20 pounds and 30 pounds
and they just let they put them in there
and they let them go
what why it's a competition they usually
let them go right oh yeah they just want
to get the weight yeah they just want to
get the weight of them
back out they're just a sport fish you
could eat they're largemouth bass you
can eat them
but that's not something yeah most
people most people don't like
yeah i wouldn't want to eat it's like
like uh um
javelinas and hogs and stuff but a lot
of people that go hunting for those
things they don't eat them
oh really yeah well they just happened
in the trophy case
yes i'm like no they're the hogs yeah no
yeah i heard who it's talking about i
think maybe tim kennedy's talking about
it they killed
i raised cam haynes on rogue talk about
like it's bad me
yeah like there's so much better meat
you just kill those things yeah i don't
have it
i don't know oh there's the fish that's
pretty much it
well he's real tiny yes it was like the
smallest thing i've ever caught
it's a beautiful fish that's a
largemouth bass that's smaller
is it why is it a majestic kind of color
to it
it's a cool looking fish and they have
giant mouths so they can actually eat
little baby ducks
they even eat ducks sometimes if they're
big enough they eat ducks yeah like
small ducks yeah like the ugly duckling
[ __ ] eating him yep
so he came out recently yes i guess he
was sober for 16 years your boy dax
shepard
and finally uh he had a relapse and he
talked about on his podcast as well
yeah he because he he broke his uh he
got a motorcycle accident
so he started getting painkillers yo
dude and then he started he was like
then i just realized i was using him as
happiness
he's married to christian so he relapsed
yeah christian bale
yeah yeah i wonder
kristen bell justin bell yeah what did i
say
christian i wonder if people are mean to
him
probably what do you feel like you were
mean to everybody yeah
especially wait what do you mean mean to
himself you know like yeah social media
would be mean to him
why would anyone be mean to malek why
would he
wait hold on now brother what did that
mean you got too much dip on your chip
what did you do
you got too much difference
now wait they bullied him nice and he's
great he's feeling grateful for the
support he
okay i think he relapse after 16 years
but everybody everyone makes mistakes
people gotta understand yeah
come on yeah but he was like known as
that guy you know he yeah
he used to be really wild and then he's
been you know
sober for 16 years for him to relapse
pretty crazy i want to know
what it what i mean he got injured and
then you yeah he got [ __ ] up yeah
broke his arm i think he's collarbone
yeah
so he had to have surgery so then they
gave him painkillers ain't got it and
that's what caught him again yeah caught
him again
matt you remember like in denzel in
flight when he kept looking at that
fridge and
he had the court yeah yeah they drank
all right he drunk all
of it yeah he went into the courtroom he
won the coconut ground right now
have you had any like anything close to
relapsing at all no
nothing oh pretty good man and you're
around it
yeah i'm around sober comedian like god
bless you man we got to realize
three bottles just to clarify i'm not
sober i don't consider myself
well i'm sorry because i'll hit a joint
every now and then whatever
and i'm not like i don't know but uh
so sober meaning so it means you don't
do anything nothing but you don't drink
you won't do
any drugs to me sober for you would be
alcohol because you're an alcoholic
correct
yes so to me not having a drink mean
you're sober
right i mean because i guess i see your
own definition maybe
yeah i guess it depends where you label
weed like to me
weed is the now yeah that's how i feel
about it too i go i'm gonna go
leave weed alone you know yeah you'll
smoke every now and then
it's like yeah once in a while it's a
blue moon it's not like a it's not a
um do those cbd joints
shout out to the same [ __ ] yeah no it's
not wait wait cbd is going it's not
no it doesn't have thc in it it's like
uh you know like kombucha they say it
has
alcohol in it it's like that for the cb
what just smoke a real [ __ ] joint
kabusha guy
wait alcohol yeah
it's only based off they ferment
something it's fermented fruit
yeah so there's it's like uh there's
there's hard kombucha which is actually
the heart
and then like the regular kombuchas have
like three or two percent i think
yeah hell no there's hard kombuchas that
are legit
yeah they may not be the green one the
green one
the green they're probably five yeah
what point
but you know what now if you have to be
i think 18 or 21 or older
if you get the gt one it's a black label
now
because the other ones are they they
they're like not as good
yeah there's black man kombucha is nasty
as [ __ ]
hell no it's good i think i'm about to
get something it's good for me
really yeah how y'all know i'm tipsy
because y'all watch the news that's how
y'all know
yeah they're getting hard kombuchas
which are pretty cool yeah
yeah but yeah so you don't think you're
you don't define yourself as being
straight
sober so yeah because i mean yeah like i
said i'll hit a joint once in a blue
moon
you know but like airbnb maybe
i saw that text i was like all right
it's one of the two
yeah i did it at one time yeah that was
we already know the roof that's not like
don't worry the the investigation went
down yeah yeah
that's nice yeah no i'm not really it
doesn't matter oh
we got in trouble because at the airbnb
you're not allowed to smoke yeah
and someone from our camp smoked in
there and they sent us this terrible
email trying to mail this money
do you know who did it yes yeah okay
okay
yeah it's kind of a boom in business
i've never seen that one now yeah it's
cool
is that so that is full on alcohol like
a light beer so what is a healthy buzz
like i don't understand like yo you
supposed to get a buzz and you feel like
yo this is good
i mean you're gonna be losing you you
feel it and [ __ ] but it's not healthy
but like with drinking i always say like
i don't know yeah it does
scare me you know what i mean like i
like there's times i'll have nightmares
about uh somebody no i'm not pissing on
somebody that's not a nightmare
yeah drinking like i wake up like like
kind of you see me drinking in the green
room
no see like because i don't i don't make
it about other people
yeah like i don't make my my drinking
about other people like hey
would you not do that no no that's it's
my [ __ ]
problem it's not you're the one with the
issue yeah i'm the one with the issue
but yeah like
i'm getting it if i if if it happened
again yeah it'd be i feel like i'd be
crazier like i'd go harder be a problem
you know what i mean that's
because that's the thing it's like you
know you try to get back to it the
regular way like you did it's like oh
[ __ ] is there
a wild turkey there's some people who
can't be around any of it yeah see
i'm i'm not like that because i don't
make it about other people i'd rather it
fall on me yeah you know what i mean
because it's like yeah
you yeah you can drink you you're gonna
handle it
you can handle it you can turn it off
like you know i've seen you drink i
don't think i've ever seen you like
now like if i go to like bars are very
tough for me
like i get high anxiety really and i and
i can't even
say i get anxiety but but that's the
only time
i get anxiety is like being in a bar
yeah just cause like you know like it's
just like a lot of people's actions so
i just have to step out yeah it's
triggering so like i have to just step
out the situation so it's just like
don't go there so it's like hey this is
a not a place i should be it's not like
i'm gonna be like hey bars you need to
[ __ ] change this
i don't i can't remember last time i was
like drunk drunk i always get on like
i'll know when i'm going on stage i'm
like all right no more because i have
one more
then i could get a little resting one
don't you
have one restaurant on the stage yeah
just yeah
honestly i don't even really see you
take a sip out of the resting one no
it's weird i have it up there it's good
i'll do it i'll do it sometimes between
jokes if you don't have like a loud
applause i'll grab a quick sip but yeah
i don't i never finish it on stage
that's what i'm saying i was like yeah i
don't think i've ever seen you like
never
backstage though i'll sip on that double
yeah they would they would check the
whiskey petey sent us
really good whiskey thank you for the
ketchup who was it whiskey pee pee pee
pee send us some ketchup
is that it dudes that's pretty much it
mm-hmm
whiskey pete much loved it there he is
not like you never had a sip right i
never drink now yeah
because my grandfather he was just
always drunk and i was like i don't
wanna i don't want that
uh that's not whiskey you had him before
he said that's not whiskey that's not at
all there he is right there whiskey
ginger oh no that's [ __ ] ginger
i'll tell you right now where are you
maybe i'm spelling it wrong
because they do ey and there he is right
chris christopher
yes sir that's him yeah he sent us a
nice little gift bag he's a
very tall person really shout out to
whiskey pete yeah he's trying to talk
oh yeah he is definitely tall visual
still doing the damn thing
all right kids let's wrap this [ __ ] up
is that it that's it
yeah covered a lot guys thanks for
coming firing the kids
i like that uh rest of october is off
for me but i'm back
in phoenix with these boys phoenix stand
up live is november 5th through the 7th
then nashville zaney's with some these
guys and
some friends nashville zany's november
19th
21st get your tickets now tfatkay.com
october 15th through the 18th uh tampa
florida
and uh oh and i'll be headlining my
hometown i haven't put those tickets up
yeah empty
yeah i'll be headed uh headlining tibia
improv november
the thanksgiving weekend i think it's
november 27th
through whatever through that sunday so
friday saturday sunday i'll put those uh
i know right
i was like wait what is it i know what
i'm doing when i do it because i do it
okay no but yeah we'll announce it once
you do it though yeah we'll announce it
but tampa gets tickets for chappelle now
october 15th through the 18th yeah
all right t5k.com for me guys thank you